[Music]
[Applause]
ross tucker host of the ross tucker
football podcast he also works as a
color analyst for cbs in westwood 1.
he'll be in the westwood one booth
saturday night buffalo it's uh the
patriots and the bills and then he'll be
working sidelines for uh the monday
night game with the cardinals and the
rams and he joins us on the program
always great to have you we appreciate
you taking some time give me the uh the
loss that would have the most fallout if
i said cowboys rams bucks chiefs bills
or other
oh that's a great question dan um
i'm gonna i'm gonna say cowboys maybe
i'm gonna go cowboys uh you know my
initial reaction was the rams
just because it would be an awful look
if
they took a step back after the trade
they made for matthew stafford i mean
they won a playoff game last year they
got to the divisional round last year
that would not be a good look for mcvay
and stafford if they weren't able to win
a playoff game this year but they're
kind of
they're kind of committed to those guys
right there really wouldn't be a whole
lot of fallout it would still be mcvay
and stafford
next year cowboys are a little bit
different
because if they lose the 49ers which by
the way i think is a distinct
possibility i just recorded the ross
tucker podcast that's the one underdog i
picked to win out right dan i picked the
niners to win that game
because of the amount of teams that are
interested
in kellen moore and dan quinn
i wonder
if jerry jones doesn't think
i don't want to lose that guy or that
guy whichever one he chooses and elects
to make one of them the head coach and
moves on from mike mccarthy you have to
acknowledge there's some possibility of
that if the cowboys lose this game
especially if there's any type of game
management clock management issue
anything like that
but if i look at kellen moore and dan
quinn who which
of those coordinators can they
least afford to lose
it's a good question
the the thing i come back to
on that is
how do you really know what kellen moore
is like as a head coach
he doesn't have any experience with it
i guess i would probably say
kellen moore
i think he's done a pretty good job
i i agree that dan quinn did a nice job
this year
but i feel like they've got some pretty
darn good personnel on defense that he's
been able to
to take advantage of trayvon diggs year
two micah parsons is a rookie
i don't know they're probably even my
guess though is that there'd be some
hesitation
from jerry jones to make kellen moore
the head coach so he would probably move
on from mccarthy and go to dan quinn
again we're there's a whole lot of
hypotheticals but that's my guess
you played in cold weather you played in
buffalo you played in new england
how big of a deal is this to the players
who play and what players in particular
if so
really big deal to quarterbacks
receivers and kickers
somebody told me this week i didn't
realize that i started
in one of the 10 coldest games
in buffalo bills history
it was 2004 it's actually at cincinnati
if you can believe that dan and i
remember the game distinctly because
i went out before the game pre-game
warm-ups with just a t-shirt and shorts
on and chad johnson was yelling at me
like hey buddy you're going to be cold i
was like i'm all right i'm all right you
know what's funny by the way
i mean i guess i was 315 pounds or
whatever and i was maybe 25 years old i
really wasn't that cold
now i'm 250 pounds and 42 years old i'm
freezing like i get i get five degrees
colder every year i mean i don't but by
the time i'm 70 i'm gonna move to like
puerto rico or so like i i know why
people go south i get way colder every
year um you know what i remember about
that game so first of all it's offensive
lineman one thing guys would do
to protect their skin
is you rub vaseline on your skin
to protect the layers it's funny i just
saw on twitter even here in pennsylvania
dan they said
don't go outside for more than 30
minutes because your skin could get
frostbitten well what are the nfl
players are going to do what are the
bills the patriots are going to do
they're going to be out for more than 30
minutes and i just think to remember
after that game it stung taking the
shower you had to start with like a cold
shower and then
slowly move it up because your skin was
like
so raw that if you went to a hot shower
it it like it felt like it burned well
that's frostbite ross that's that's the
onset of frostbite
yeah i guess
i mean it's not good i never wore
sleeves though um two two more things
you need to know dan number one is
it makes the ball
a lot harder and bigger the ball expands
the colder it is so i can remember a
couple games i started at center
where i would like if it was really cold
in buffalo
i would go the the stuff they spray on
your ankle before they tape your ankles
i'd be like i'd say to the trainer hey
act like you're taping my ankles and i'd
have them like spray the stuff on my
hand because i didn't know if that was
legal or not to have that stuff on your
hand so i'd have them spray like the
ankle spray stuff
on my hand just so i could have a better
grip but i totally understand why
some people at some point
might like if there's a little bit less
air in the football i'm not going there
but i'm just saying because it is it's
much harder to grip
if you have smaller hands the colder it
is it makes it harder if there's more
fumbles because the ball pops out harder
to catch the ball is like a rock
i also wonder the uh philosophy game
plan with the patriots this time around
with this kind of weather in buffalo
can new england
employ the same kind of offense
that you don't have mac jones throw the
football in this game against buffalo
i think they should try
i really think they should try you know
mac jones has not played well
during the last month of the season
i think if they can play keep away from
josh allen who was lights out in the
last matchup with the patriots that
would be a pretty darn good strategy and
here's the thing the bills play more
nickel defense
than any team in the nfl they almost
never have three linebackers out there
because they love their nickelback taran
johnson who had that pick six against
the ravens last year in the playoffs
that's one reason why i think belichick
went heavy
in the first matchup with the tight ends
and ran the ball just to get the bill's
defense which by the way is ranked
number one in the nfl just to get them
to have to do something they don't like
to do just just like make them have a
guy out there they don't want to have
out there that's not normal for them
having the three linebackers out there
we're talking to ross tucker you can uh
listen to the ross tucker football
podcast he'll also be working the
buffalo patriots game and also working
the uh cardinals in the rams game as
well
the the rams game is interesting cowboys
game is interesting because i think both
of those teams
could lose
i wouldn't be surprised if either lost
um
but then i you know there's part of it
that i wouldn't be surprised if they won
comfortably i i just think that
that's the way they're going to be
you know as we go through the playoffs
if they continue to advance
it's really hard to be consistent where
you're putting together you're playing a
really good opponent and
you gotta you gotta win a game where
you're not gonna play your best if i
said the rams or the cowboys weren't
going to play their best which one has a
better chance of winning
the rams i i would say the rams simply
because
i don't feel like the cardinals are
playing their best football right now
they've only won one of their last five
games just not good i mean and obviously
they can change everything around and
get hot during the playoffs but it's not
a good way to be going into the
postseason both their running backs
james connor and chase edmonds are
banged up we'll see if
jj walk could do anything but it really
does feel like the cardinals have been a
different team
ever since hopkins got hurt meanwhile
dan if the cowboys don't play their best
they're losing i mean the niners are
undervalued they're ten and seven they
lost the two games where jimmy g didn't
start they lost a game where jimmy g got
hurt against the titans that's three
losses right there that i think they
lost the game where debo samuel didn't
play
the niners when they have all their guys
they're a good team and you don't even
have to take my word for it that the
cowboys don't feel good about themselves
i mean dan why else would they have all
their starters playing in the fourth
quarter
last saturday night
against the eagles practice squad guys
you know whether they say they wanted to
build up their confidence or they wanted
to get on a roll or a rhythm the cowboys
playing dak and all their starters into
the fourth quarter last saturday night
against the eagle that told us i think
that they don't feel great about how
they're playing they think that they're
a little off
i know that you know the eagles quite
well they didn't beat anybody who was
any good this year and now you're going
to face the buccaneers in tampa weather
will probably be an issue with rain
how do the eagles
beat the buccaneers
yeah they gotta they got to just run the
ball right down their throat and really
they're calling for 20 25 mile an hour
winds
this is
the best thing possible for the eagles i
mean the windier it is the more the
advantage goes to the eagle's ability to
run the football and jalen hurts ability
to run the football i have a tough time
picturing the eagles winning the game
unless jalen hurts rushes for over 50
yards so the windier it is the better
the harder the rain the better i'm sure
brady will still somehow figure out
something
but that plays to the eagles favor
they've been able to run on everybody
and i think that bucks have given up
over 100 yards rushing
in four of their last five or six games
so the bucks are not their run defense
is not what it was
that said dan you know i do the eagles
pre-game as well for wip in philadelphia
and say it out loud okay like sometimes
in life you have to say it out
loud head coach nick ciriani and
quarterback jalen hurts in their first
playoff games ever
beat tom brady and the defending super
bowl champ bucks on the road i mean i
have a tough time with that do you
realize dan wait are you saying the
eagles have no chance
i think they have a chance okay i have a
tough time actually
picturing it happening i've if you had
me on on monday
i i have a tough time picturing saying
the eagles got that done it would be
incredible
on so many levels if they did
but wow that would be i mean you talk
about and i know the point spreads not
that bad last time i checked it's like
nine and a half so it's not like a
gigantic upset but you have to admit
you know the eagles season win total
coming into the year was six and a half
people thought they'd win six and a half
games if they were able to beat brady
in the first playoff game that would be
one of the more surprising playoff
results in recent years
safe travels always great to talk to you
and are you going to rub vaseline on
your arms in buffalo
no i'm not but thank goodness steve
tasker's on the sideline for us and i'm
in the booth
and i'm i'm i'm going to lobby hard to
keep the glass the window shut because
zero degree damn zero degree it would be
a better broadcast for the listeners if
i was warm i mean it's about the
listeners dan
but i want you to give us that feeling
that's that's your job as a color
analyst you should be out there with no
jacket on short sleeve and let us know
that we could almost feel it through
your bones when we're listening to you
that's why tasker's on the sideline he's
the best in the business because he's
tougher tasker is tougher than you yes
i'm not tough anymore i i freely admit
that i don't need to be tough anymore i
could you know i used to play in the nfl
i was tough now i just like to eat and
drink and call football games did you
ever urinate in your uniform
how do you know that almost every game
what
oh yeah pretty much every game oh yeah
so here's the way it works you're
drinking so much pedialyte and gatorade
that i could i was good through the
first half
and at halftime i would go
take a leak whatever
but by like 10 minutes left in the
fourth quarter dan
i had to pee so bad what were my choices
like call timeout and walk up to the
locker room no what's the etiquette
uh oh you sit down on the bench here let
me see you sit down on the bench okay
and then you get a couple of those like
gatorade you're reenacting this
oh yeah yeah you sit down on the bench
you get a couple of those gatorade
towels okay
and then you take two gatorade towels
and you put it you know in your crotch
because you want to try to absorb as
much of the urine as possible
and then you just go
and and you soak up as much you squeeze
the area to get as much out of your
pants and onto the gatorade towels you
put the gatorade towels in the trash you
don't put them back where somebody else
would use them but dan the last thing i
wanted fourth quarter four minutes left
i didn't want to feel like i had to pee
like i don't be like oh i got to block
uh bryant young or leroy glover but oh i
really feel like i have to pee no you
pee like a man in your pants and then
you go out there and you play
thank you ross
see you dad okay that's ross tucker
you pee your pants like a man yeah then
you go out and play yeah that might be
the the next bet that's if you lose if
you say the eagles have no chance now
you have to pee your pants in a towel